[Music]
i recently wrapped a picture a motion
picture a talkie yes it was an
old-fashioned talking it was a christmas
movie that vince vaughn wrote it's gonna
be very funny i hope it was a lot of fun
and and uh we had a great crew
i was inspired by a friend of mine who
was very good at giving gifts and i gave
little rap gifts to to
not to pat myself in the back wow very
unlike you though i'm very surprised to
learn this right yeah but it felt really
good and was a nice way of um i got to
actually like really thank the people
who do
the harder work i get to do like the fun
stuff and go out and play and um anyway
i gave a bunch of gifts and i was
reminded of the last time i gave a bunch
of little gifts like that was sadly when
i was a child when i was a kid i
remember in a little family room desk
and i would sit there
and make little crafts and i called it
like my workshop like i i fancied myself
like little like one of santa's albs i i
like the idea of being one of his elves
and like making gifts for people they
must have been ridiculous i'm trying to
remember some of the things i met i
wonder if my own piper kept those i
can't believe you don't remember this
feels like a created memory to me
because i grew up in the same house as
you and i have no memory of you having a
little
elf
station you know what we should in our
family room you should call mom right
now she's doing yoga now she's no she is
yeah
um well i'm sorry i don't remember it
but i i can't believe i'm but i'm happy
that you have like found i rekindled
that you rekindled that uh desire to
give gifts yeah and it felt so good and
um it was nice to this sounds like a
braggy pat yourself on the back all
right no no but it was nice anyway my
point is thanks to everyone and it's
nice to give gifts and uh it's nice to
give
so give give more to to people who have
you you feel are deserving of them tell
me more oh sage oh generous sage
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life for short i am
your now self-conscious and
[Music]
is always just my you're generous i'm
not great you're not a gift we didn't
grow up that we grew up with a lot of
guilt and like that's something we
should unpack in therapy but um yeah
we're not on the show christmas was like
there was pressure to get a gift i
remember for each of our family members
yeah you know and why was that why was
there so much negativity about gifts i i
didn't feel that much
you have more guilt when it comes to
gifts than i do i think i just remember
there being pressure to get it done
uh and i remember like the day before
christmas or like the 23rd of december
there was pressure to like i haven't
found all my gifts yet
and it never felt that pleasurable i
know you know it felt more like
uh an onus yeah it was just so close to
anus i was just thinking that you don't
bother everything that notice
it is so close every time i write it
you've texted me onus recently yeah yeah
well speaking of anus
oh no no why are we talking about gift
giving well you know what i just
realized uh when i was doing this
christmas movie because it's there's
there's christmasy stuff ever it's a
satire of hallmark christmas movies but
there they still shot it like a
christmas movie so there's like really
great sets everywhere and it's crazy
it's so it's like an explosion of
christmas i thought you said great sex
everywhere but i was set
you know like a typical christmas movie
like utah yeah yeah i know i wouldn't
think there is a lot of sex in utah
there is they produce a lot they sure do
and um i gotta say they're very
friendly um
to me anyway sure
i don't know what that means but um yeah
but you you think i was thinking i've
been thinking about christmas because
i've been like immersed in it with with
these sex these sex
uh and i started thinking
i i'd see like little
stores and trinkets stuff in stores and
i think oh so and so would like that and
i think what i and i did this i bought
this one thing and i said i think um i'm
going to try
i'll talk to you in a couple months but
i'm going to try to buy whenever i have
that thought i'm gonna try to get things
for people that i think might enjoy it
in my life
and do the the christmas so i'm not i
don't have that feeling you just
described it's a good idea it's a good
plan yeah why are we talking about gift
giving though i'll tell you because um
you know and elves
okay okay
as a child i uh i you know i fancied
myself a little elf a little gift giving
elf and you love the rudolph the
red-nosed reindeer i sure did hermie who
was the elf on rudolph and um in fact i
remember thinking at the dentist because
hermie wanted to be a dentist so bad i
remember thinking when i was at the
dentist
you should be so lucky like you're so
blase about this job you have and like
their elves who are dying to do this job
i want to be a dentist was that code for
i think there's some
theories about that but what but also so
we're talking about elves and because i
will tell you
uh our guest today our very special
guest was in the movie elf
uh our guest is
the new girl herself we've had so many
other cast members almost all of them
and now we have
her jess it's jess uh our guest today is
zoe deschanel well you just yelled that
i did
it's a big uh it's a big gap big get
yeah zoe is um an old friend she is uh
obviously the star of new girl star of
elf many other
great movies uh almost famous we talked
about many five hundred days of summer
oh man she's done a lot of good stuff
yeah all the real girls
yes um oh my god i forgot about that
flakes with keira o'donnell our friend
and she's
she's one half
of the amazing sister group emily and
zoe
she's one half of the amazing musical
group she and him yes she's the she
uh she and him and him is uh m ward um
great they are
really
talented god i know i mean does it get
much more talented than her well uh
we're about to hear that i don't really
think so she's got a new podcast out
with a former friend of the show a still
friend of the show
they don't become former no i've made
that mistake before lamorne morris uh
and hopefully a future friend hannah
simone a new girl another new girl
co-star and it's all about new girls
like a new girl uh i did the show i
should know how to describe it better
it's a re-watch
but they don't really watch i mean we i
did a bunch of episodes of new girl and
we sort of talked about but is that the
general term for these types of shows oh
i guess a rewatch podcast i guess so
yeah i could be wrong it has to do with
nuke it's new girl so what's it called
it's called uh welcome to our show cool
all right and welcome to our show
life is short which you're listening to
and here is our guest my old friend
the very sweet funny zoe deschanel
life could be a dream
[Music]
are you in austin
no i'm i'm in l.a okay you move back
i was only there for like
maybe six months oh oh why did i think
you oh okay i had my daughter but that's
it oh okay uh and you have a couple of
cool guitars and a banjo do you play the
banjo yeah i've got a lot yeah i mean i
mean
i can pick up any stringed instrument
pretty easily and i got you oh that's so
cool
but the banjo i hear is a lot harder
yeah
i i'm not a great banjo player so i
wouldn't really know i just like well
i'll just make my own tuning
you know you for me it's all about um
um
cheating
um by playing with tunings and then i
just make a tuning that i like
and then make the banjo easy and adapt
to me not i'm not adapting to the banjo
oh i see i don't know you could do that
you know it's like i'm not a banjo
player like you know they're good people
who are banjo players i just like have
it as a you know everything
that i have is like a writing tool oh
really that's so cool but you if you
were to but you can play the banjo
without sounding it without it sounding
like twingy and weird and like dying
it was not twangy because it's twenty
this is a four-string banjo
um that's kind of more typical to like
uh
you know
it's like a jazz banjo kind of you know
like dixieland
not like kermit's banjo
um kermit's banjo i don't
kermit joe is probably a five-string fan
oh was that so he was that your passion
before actually i can't i
banjo is not that's not your forte
instrument so we're
no please because like banjo players
will be like no no i i have a banjo it
doesn't mean i'm good at playing the
banjo i just have it like i have a lot
of instruments because i like playing
instruments and you know i'm probably
like best at piano or ukulele but um i
have a banjo and i have lots of guitars
and i have bass and a drum kit oh i like
to play music you're so and the best
music i love your music did you start
when you were a kid
yes yeah i started
pretty young and i started
piano just kind of teaching myself how
to play piano just because i liked it so
much and then finally it was like my
parents had to get me lessons because i
was
just like begging
i was in music class in school in
elementary school and this was before i
started taking piano and
they had all kinds of instruments mainly
like um
you know kind of uh xylophone type
instruments yeah yeah
all those yeah like the kind of
metallophone uh glockenspiel
xylophone marimba whatever that type of
that category of instrument and um
and that they have a lot of element is
mattel phones an instrument i think i
can't remember i'm pretty sure that's
what you call it all of those sound
familiar from the casio i remember those
names from my little casio keyboard
yeah yeah yeah oh yeah the sk1 uh
greatest keyboard of all time i think so
i think that's what it was just the
basic one
yeah yeah from the 80s yes from when you
were a kid yeah yeah it's a
masterpiece that one i they're like kind
of expensive now because they don't make
them anymore and i just i
i want to get one i wanted to get one
for my kids but then when i was like
four hundred dollars i was like that's
true
no kidding
because they're like collectors items
i know i just bought them like a new
keyboard which is probably technically
better than the sk1 but that's really
special
um how old are you do they have they
been clamoring to play zoe so they yeah
they take like music classes
they're four and six yeah so they take
general music and the reason why i put
them in general music
um is that when i was a kid and i would
take music in school they taught us the
you know a like a blues chord
progression and i was like this is so
cool this sounds so good and but then
when your parents put you in piano
lessons then they want to teach you
classical music and not like i don't
like classical music but i definitely am
more attracted to like a more modern
music i think now
with kids it's really cool because they
can learn
music through a different lens than
just classical you know yeah i guess
that's that was the same with me i i
took it begrudgingly i was kind of like
the opposite of you my parents were like
you have to play this to be a
to be a well-rounded are your parents do
your parents play music or they my mom
was kind of like a a musical theater
well she was an actress so she loved
musical theater so she and my dad loved
mom's an actress too oh yeah
yes and your dad is
caleb um so were you was that something
that you were just surrounded by zoe
because like when i was a kid that was
the last thing i wanted to do just only
because i saw
well i saw kind of like kind of the
shittier elements of
being an actor you know i saw a lot of
rejection i'd like schlep around the
city with her from audition to audition
it just felt like there was a lot of
stress there was a lot of pressure
surrounding it so it it was it certainly
wasn't glamorous
i knew she was an actress but i didn't
really connect it to being bad like i
just knew that she liked it didn't
really feel like there was an anxiety
right
no could see how that might be so it
wasn't any it was a thing that was like
in the house it was just um yes it was
normalized it was normal and and we
always want both my sister like well so
emily said she wanted to do something
different but now she says she always
wanted to be an actress oh rewriting
herself both like oh well
we we both she said she was scared to
say that she wanted oh really
yeah why
i don't know i always like was like not
me
i was like
here we are
i also like
we watch like
like old videos from when i was a kid oh
my god that's like crazy
did they try to curb that were they like
now zoey everyone these earth or did
they indulge you
they thought it was funny yeah because
like when you have something
my son like talks all the time about
movies he's gonna make he's four they're
like make no sense and then he does the
soundtrack to them right still sing the
sound drag
and they're all like about like you know
dinosaurs and sharks yeah all kinds of
fun i bet they'd do well i bet they'd be
like hits
oh i'm sure yeah like sharknado
yeah oh sharknado definitely would have
come from his brain um but yeah
so what's an example of one
of a movie that he's that he's conceived
that he's um okay well
there was one um they pitched me
um
old blueberries okay i'm listening it
might have been we like the title
we open up
oh yeah it might have been blueberry it
might have been purple berry i'm not
sure i can't remember it's a fats domino
biopic
it's one
right
um it's not um
it it has uh sharks mastodons and
t-rexes in blueberry
in in the movie okay
um and he's doing the score
um and he's directing it and his
sister's gonna be in it oh that's nice
his um stuffed animal
uh that he's very attached to
so um yeah so that one and uh
development i mean i think it's a hit so
why is it called blueberry if all these
pitching it to netflix
they are desperate for content
okay listen
i don't know about i don't know how
desperate
um but um uh so
so why is it called blueberry
i wish i knew
there's so you know what it's cute if i
could just i mean it's very cute i bet
you want to get into his bra i bet there
are times where you're like god i wish i
could
really get into your brain and
understand why you're saying nothing
cute yeah he's so cute guy it's also so
good to see you it's really i know so
good to see you do you know that i still
have you in my phone as paul ginsberg oh
really i had your isuzu
i don't know if that's personal but
where did that come from no it's not
personal um it's sweet my dad my parents
named me zoe so they could call me zuzu
that was like no kidding a conscious
choice i don't know why they didn't just
make me do if they really wanted to call
me zuzu but it was part of they liked
the name zoe and then
then i think they thought zuzu was a
nickname not a
not a proper name and so they
you know so my dad every
everyone growing up not every not all of
my friends but my family called me zuzu
uh now a lot of my friends call me zuzu
so uh uh-huh so they zoos who came
before zoey i guess zoey's just more
proper maybe they felt like um they call
me both you know but my dad would always
call me zuzu so oh
that's really cute did they have a cute
nickname for emily um
um yeah yeah that's okay it's good
it's fine
you um did she start acting
professionally before you
no so she's older but than me but she
went to college and was like you know
studying theater and i started in high
school because i had this crossroads i
don't know
yeah well yeah i went to crossroads and
and um
i don't know if you had this but
no maybe you said you didn't because
you're you're of your mom and and
maybe not being attracted to acting but
i
wanted to act really so much i wanted to
be a child actor that was my dream yeah
and i kept asking and they're like
well that you know they're like we're in
the business and they must have been
nervous about it see
well they were like we don't always see
the best outcomes for childhood i get it
and we've worked with a lot of them and
we just don't think it's the best thing
for you and it's you know it's your job
right now to be a kid it's good for them
to study and to you know be in school
and play with your friends and and do
all the stuff you know that you need to
do to you know really be a kid so that
was really frustrating for me but it was
good because i got to be a kid yeah and
i was really excited and determined and
not at all burned out by the time i
started and so our deal was um and i
think it was a good one because yeah um
my mom was like
you know i know you really want to act
she's like once you get your driver's
license you can get an agent
she's like because then you can drive
yourself to auditions
in hindsight are you are you great are
you glad they did that
so glad yeah yeah i i would do the same
thing for my kids if they really had
like the goal to like make blueberry
turn it into
well they have to workshop at first i i
would love to be a part of that workshop
yeah would you like to be invited
do you want to play a shark i'm not
kidding zoey it's it's not a bad idea
it's well
it's what it's whatever charlie you know
it's it's up to him uh uh ultimately but
i would
okay um
i'll see what he said
any of those would be a stretch would be
a real challenge
would be a fun challenge but i it's not
a terrible idea to like
maybe they've someone's done that to
turn like a kid script like charlie's
script
into i think it would be really fun to
kind of do a reading
at least
or i think it would be fun to like have
you know a
you know
um
just kind of get into like the
the basics of making um
movies and so fun and interesting to
them that's what they love watching
movies do they see you doing it i mean
are they like
miss or does that have been demystified
i think i'm a voice my kids think i'm a
voice actor oh they don't no cause like
i i was in trolls yeah oh they must love
them and then i did winnie the pooh
music for winnie the pooh they know that
i'm a
singer but they don't really like they
saw elf i guess but they were both kind
of confused but i was they're a little
young for it again yeah i guess my
daughter was like it's scary
it is i can't scare you i can see that
through the lens of a six or
six anything suspenseful is scary well
i'll show you i'm like no that's not
fear yeah
that's suspense yeah that's cute that's
funny i but i i what is their
association i wonder if i i'm imagining
them
thinking that maybe you know winnie the
pooh you're somehow associated directly
with these they
think and know that i know santa
yeah so that's i'm like won't know him
yeah you know yeah and i do like saying
i know him
i know him so anyone that's done like a
voice like i know a lot of the people
who've done the voices for um oh yeah
that they like so i'll be like i know
him i know yeah i worked with him and
they're like it's so cr yeah but they
think everyone has a tv show as well
because my sister has a tv show my
boyfriend has a tv show my
brother-in-law has a team it's like
everybody has tv shows yeah so they're
like that's normal i don't think they
even really know because they watch only
animated stuff so again yeah
you know oh i think they don't quite get
it you know yeah they're so yeah one of
the best moments i had as a as an uncle
was um i mean this is when i it didn't
last very long because they
i i but i got so many points for it
initially was um taryn killum does the
voice of nature cat which is my my
nephew's favorite show he's obsessed
with he's allowed to watch nature watch
that yeah oh it's uh i almost said oh
it's fantastic
um it sounds pbs i think but um
pbs has great kids yeah yeah it's it's
like yeah um in uh educational stuff but
uh educational [ __ ] but um
taryn left a message
for out for um my nephew and it and it
just blew his mind i mean i could see my
my brother recorded it um took a video
of it and it's so cute to see
to hear him
hear this character say his name it it
like oh my god you could see it it's so
cool yeah
i had the same thing with um
josh gad oh oh we loved frozen one and
frozen two and and elsie and charlie
were homesick from school
er no they it was last year so they were
just sick they weren't homesick from
anything
in a bad mood and and then we watched
frozen too and then
elsie's like
do you think olaf is a kid
or a grown-up
and i was like
so i'll ask him oh my god no you don't
mom did they believe you at first
they believed me they were like really
and i was like yeah i know him i'll ask
him so i sent a message i said um my you
know little girl
and my little butt they would like to
know if olaf was a kid or a grown-up and
he sent me a message a message as olaf
sent them a message as olaf um
uh
saying i'm a kid like you oh that's cute
that's cute so sweet they were so
excited and happy she's like i knew it
yeah and then they sent a message oh man
oh they must be man it's hard not to it
must be i mean i like giggling you know
the best yes they must be so cute i it
is hard not to talk about them only
because
i it's it's it's also a part of your
life that i i haven't seen you in in
that long i mean i haven't really talked
to you a long time yeah and it's
obviously such a huge
thing and it must be such great fodder
too just like that they must be like
constantly entertaining you
they are i will say kids constantly
entertain you yeah and it's so wonderful
they get more and more fun yeah
you know always saying just cute funny
things i i keep a list of all the funny
things oh that's good that's no it's oh
that's great um
that is really cute what what did
were you like i mean you were very
precocious sounding um so it sounds like
you are a little bit
like them you must see a lot of yourself
in them
yeah yeah no definitely i think they're
you know they're they're their own
people but yeah definitely
my daughter looks a lot like me so it's
always it's f you know it's fun to like
yeah dress like and stuff like that yeah
dude what what um so when you so when at
16 do you make like a beeline for
is it do you go to your mom's agent was
it was that a um no no no uh she didn't
have an agent you know when i was she
she kind of like went she would like act
on and off yeah and um but here's what
happened um i
was well it was it was through my
parents that i got this opportunity i
was doing tons of theater in high school
and i was i was doing a lot of musical
theater
it must be a good departure they must
have a great theater at crossroads
yeah they have great theater great
teachers and everything and just great
like
all the like arts especially i mean all
the academics too we had great yeah it
was just a great school but um
i
was doing theater there pretty seriously
and um
a friend of my
mom's
was like a famous um and or he is sorry
um i should say that again um a friend
of my mom's is like a famous broadway
actor john rubenstein oh yeah and he was
doing he was the original pippen on
broadway wow
and done tons of shows and um
he was directing
a version of into the woods oh no
kidding and at a theater company
um that he was a part of and they needed
like a young girl to play little red
riding hood oh yeah
and hello little girl
right so i
you know and i was like a belter
and so they they went they had seen me
in a lot you know they'd seen me in some
school plays and stuff like that and
knew i could sing and um act so
they were like what zoey you know it was
at first it was a reading they did it as
a reading just to see oh man i'd love to
see you
and then we did it as a show and it ran
for like seven months and i think i was
doing
five shows a week oh [ __ ] it wasn't as
many as like you know broadway or
something but i was doing school for
high school yeah and going at night
to do the show and then um
and then doing like saturday and sunday
like matinees
and
you know night performances it was like
it was it was a it was a solid amount of
work and
um
and so i did that and then i got you
know it was funny like i i just did it
because it was i you know it was a great
opportunity there were a lot of really
great people in that play and um
and you probably weren't thinking about
like or were you thinking at that time i
didn't think this is a stepping stone
yeah like oh my gosh i would love to
play that part
i love i was a big sondheim fan i you
know um always wanted to i always loved
that part yeah um and i saw i had seen
the broadway production daniel farley it
was very exciting to me yeah um and and
so i didn't think of it as like a
stepping stone or anything but it kind
of ended up being that for me because i
got a lot of good reviews um like la
times i remember i remember my first
oh man
and like all the papers
came and reviewed it which was really
cool and then i ended up getting
representation from that and then just
it took me a long time to like book a tv
show or really or a movie or anything
yeah it took me so long because i was
not good at auditioning i'm still like i
know
oh my god it's so funny because i was
thinking of you as like being so
amazingly talented like just like you're
just like
oh that's you at like
radiate town that's so nice but like
what's cool about you is that you you
are like
super
like
physically talented you're doing your
physical comedy so great but you're also
really good at like
writing your own alts oh you know and
your line delivery is so good too i
think that's a that's kind of a rare
combination i'm glad we did this
yeah yeah you got a little ego
well that's all the time we have
um oh that's so sweet so that means a
lot coming from you it's only true it's
only true but so
so you say you're bad at others well i
am too well so the only reason why i
think i am is that i never get parts
that i auditioned for that'd be good and
i'm like and it's why i'm like no no no
you don't want me to audition because i
will like apparently disappoint you i'll
think i nailed it and i didn't well
because they'll choose somebody else i'm
like did you
do my face or something yeah it's
probably your face uh it's probably me
you well i wonder if it is because i i
this is gonna sound like
braggy especially on the heels of what
you just said but i am i wonder if my
issue with auditioning is similar to
yours because you're you are a very
truthful actor and and there's something
like i mean you are just always honest
and so there's something
i think inherently like
it's it's hard to maintain that kind of
truth and honesty when you're
when you're in a room full of people
when there's that kind of setup there
it's just it's not set up to um
it's not the most honest uh situation if
that makes sense my theory is that it's
a power dynamic thing
don't like so even when i pitch stuff
there's a deficiency all that stuff like
i'm yeah like i'm better if somebody
comes to me and says like oh we know
your work and want you for this job
if i come in saying i really want this
people
don't react well to me i don't know why
and i'm wondering like if there's
something some other people are doing
who go in for just more confident
maybe as simple as like confidence
because that the thing that it was
always i think i'm like a confident
person though it's weird i have no idea
i have no idea yeah i would say you are
but i i hear stories about like there's
a story about jim kavisa where he would
go into these rooms like big rooms like
terence malik auditioning for thin red
line and they'd want to chit chat you
know and he would say and he would
ignore them and he would just say what
do you want me here is the camera you
ready and he he was like all business
okay so that's so funny because i
remember my dad did a movie with forest
whitaker yes and forrest was like
like
he was like oh yeah he's like when i
used to audition he's like i
would never
chit chat he's like i just want to get
straight to the point and you know and
i'm like that's probably better because
i nervous
i
know it's the nervous i actually think
it's the nervous talk
well and it might be the nervousness
well it's also like it's so then hard to
pivot especially if the character isn't
i mean i i was fortunate enough to play
a lot of kind of
um
lower status
nerdy
characters who um me too yeah yeah so
maybe
maybe that just naturally led to those
because we we were doing that nervous
talk thing because we
and so it's because they perceived us as
that yes because we kind of i guess
uh
by the way does that i always wanted
this does that word bother because that
word surrounds you it must follow you
the word
no
quirky nerdy
yeah
goofy i don't care at all quirky quirky
i remember the first time i heard it in
college and i was like what like i
remember somebody saying that to me i
was like yeah
as a compliment like complimentary yeah
like yeah they were like you're quirk
well it was someone who's like obsessed
with me who's basically stalking me so i
guess it must have been a compliment
no one more complimentary than a stalker
constantly come and like knock on my
door at all hours of the um day and
night um and leave me presents all the
time and call me i was like um i guess
quirky's a compliment
oh you must
wow that's a loved question oh yeah i
must have loved new girl well we well
let's give him a shout out who was that
young man no i'm kidding i don't know i
remember his name i just remember that's
it's funny that that's the first time
you heard it
yeah that was the first time i heard it
i remember hearing it and being like i
have to look that word up
and uh yeah it wasn't then it's a common
word
that's funny yeah well it wasn't common
until we made it popular that's kind of
true um but you know what anything that
makes you unique i think is good as an
actor you know because when i first
started a lot of the people that i'd see
it at all those like auditions and i did
get stuff like when i i had to have
gotten stuff auditioning but it took me
so long to get good at audrey yeah but
the the people i would see at auditions
were like very generic you know
yes and
and then it was like the thing that set
me apart that actually made me memorable
and eventually made me stand up
and stand apart from those
you know those samey kinds of true so i
i think it was an asset
[Music]
you recently bought a home that's
correct and when you did buy the home
were you did you feel prepared did you
feel like you knew about the ins and
outs of home buying absolutely not now
don't you wish you'd listen to the
podcast how to buy a home absolutely um
because no matter what stage you're in
you can start planning now because it's
it's just things are getting crazier in
the home buying market i don't have to
tell you this you just went through it
well i listened to it after i was
already well with like in the middle of
the process
so host david sadoni he's an industry
expert with years of experience and he
actually
cares about first-time homebuyers like
me he cares about you uh so he answers
tons of questions on the show things
like uh when's the best time to start
how do i start do i use my real name
when i'm buying a home will a mortgage
be more than my current monthly rent how
strong do i shake the person the
realtor's hand what can i do to take
advantage of the insane 2022
skyrocketing market should i jump in
here's the good news he just released
david just released an emergency episode
of how to buy a home all about the
bidding wars of 2022 with insider tips
and tricks to win the war david has
helped make buying a home a reality for
so many people he even connects
first-time home buyers with great local
realtors in their area so they they know
they have someone in their corner listen
to the how to buy a home podcast today
david can help find how to buy a home
wherever you listen to podcasts
do you ever have moments where you're
kind of sitting around you get bored i
find that it's nice to like not do
anything during those times you can just
kind of look off just stare at the wall
stare at the wall but occasionally
when i no longer want to do that i'll
grab my phone and i'll do a fun game
that i can play kind of absent-mindedly
that's what best fiends is uh we should
mention it is a fun game that's free to
download that's true oh i should have
led with that i like playing it when i'm
waiting for something that i'm not
excited to do like if i'm at a doctor's
office oh that's a good point or at the
dmv because if you sit with your
thoughts then the thought turns to
something that you don't like exactly so
you want you want to
get your mind off stuff it lets your
mind go it's right in the doctor's
office it's also not totally mindless
it's kind of fun
it's really engaging there are cute
characters and you solve thousands of
fun puzzles puzzles are good for the
mind to keep the mind sharp and alert
you play and then you collect more
characters kind of like how you got
really into pikachu four years ago so
their new characters and challenging
puzzles are always being added too so i
i forget what level i'm i think i'm
around
87 now
i'm nearing a hundred i'll say that oh
okay but here's the thing there's still
thousands thousands
so i've got a lot of playing ahead of me
that's for sure download best fiends
free today on the app store or google
play that's friends without the r best
fiends best fiends
[Music]
i remember seeing you in almost famous
and was that do you think how most
people
discovered you that movie
well yeah that was one of them i mean
elf was probably like
the one that like
a lot of
people saw you know just like mass
audiences but
almost famous was like the first
like that was i had done a couple movies
before that no wait i did one no two
movies the new guy uh
no i did uh mumford oh yeah with
which was an amazing experience and then
and that was like a you know kind of
like a
it was like a it would it was a really
good movie it just didn't have a huge
audi it didn't it didn't have a huge
audience but so
it got me started um
but yeah like a lot of like film buffs
uh you know like really loved almost
famous and it continues to be this movie
that people really love so that was a
really
amazing
cameron crowe both of those movies yeah
cameron crowe is amazing he's so great
and and and larry caston who did yeah
did mumford i was so lucky to work with
those guys in fact i was so spoiled
because that was like my my first few
movies were with these like amazing
directors yeah were so kind
so good to work with so generous
and then you know you don't know was not
everybody you were i know isn't that
funny i know
i had a similar thing happen with galaxy
quest it was it these people who were
like dean i loved the just really kind
that movie is so good but but i love
that but it's like and you know this you
would i would have anyway i don't know
if you you know the same is true for you
i would have done kind of anything any
movie i mean i would have done like
friday the 13th 12th you know um but it
just happened to be this really
yeah i was auditioning for like movies
of the week which i would have
totally and then i'm like they're like
they were rejecting me and then i got
hired by like these like champions
directors i'm like oh oh okay yeah it's
funny
lifetime says no
cameron crowe cameron crowe says yes
he i heard he's so
uh i've never gone to work but i just
heard he's like kinda just like sweet
delightful he is absolutely like it's
magical to work with him he's such a
just so
so kind and fun
it's like that playful thing that you
love like as an actor and he he always
would come up with really like fun he
just like is in he's like delighting and
enjoying the process of making the movie
as a director and as a writer and it's
it's like everyone kind of
ends up sharing in that journal it's the
past
does he tell you what songs he's got
because obviously music is such a huge
part of that movie does he tell you what
songs are going to be playing over
certain scenes
yeah i mean a lot of them you don't
always know exactly ahead of time like
what's
fully cleared but he had mixed cds i
remember he gave me
like two like uh
his mixes for the movie
um and um
yeah so it was really cool and then he
would play music on set he would always
have
and he knew that
[Laughter]
you were in alvin and the chipmunks is
that right i sure was oh my gosh because
i love that chipmunk song yeah you know
the chipmunks on the the christmas one
yes yeah christmas great yeah yeah so
that he had it on the soundtrack oh
that's right it's in that's right that's
right that's right and he played it for
me because he knew i liked that song i
remember him just surprisingly on set
just like he's like okay go and then it
was like it was like a
you know a shot without sound and i'm
i'm just walking down the street and he
just starts playing
he's like so
it's a delightful song made me smile
yeah i bet yeah
but did you cover that one on your album
and she and him i did
yeah
[Music]
yes
did cam did he know that you were a
singer
talented he didn't he did because there
were no like female singers in that
movie so there was like no i remember
hearing about it and hearing it was like
about 70s rock and roll and i was like
oh my god that's so cool like this was
while i was like in the audition process
and i thought like oh maybe they should
know i'm a singer you know musician
but like no all the girls were either
all the women were either like you know
the mom or the sister the groupies there
were no
no female musicians and
almost what were your
musical inspirations zoe like what were
your top um what were the album if your
life was almost famous
um you were collecting so many well i so
brian wilson um
uh i was like
would listen to beach boys i listened to
like um you know uh
um oldies radio
so like growing up that's what i loved
and so like i got really into the
beatles when i was
nine yeah yeah
and i always just like loved love love
harmony so i was into you know brian
wilson the best um
and i've got you know i've gotten to
work with him what
um yeah i got to sing on his record
my bandmate played guitar and i got to
sing on his record and i've gotten to
sing with him live what
many times he recorded a version of god
only knows with oh
my god he's like gotten to i've like
somehow manifested this and like that's
very quirky and he's such a great
yes it is very quick
that's if we had a show it would become
fairy
yeah
god only knows how quirky this is what
how did that come about how did that
happen
um dm he had dmd
no
so i met him
i went and saw i was doing a movie in
england um and i went and saw him
you know brian wilson matt hitchhikers
yes i was doing hitchhiker's
yeah so brian was doing shows
um this the smile oh yeah he
album from like start to finish amazing
he was doing those shows um
at the royal festival hall and i think
they did five shows
there in a row and i went the first
night and was like i'm coming back every
night oh yeah and i ended up meeting
like a bunch of people in his band and
somehow like
somehow at that like la you know by the
end i'm like singing um
being my baby around yeah i was like
right it's like
backstage or on stage no like they were
all back at their hotel like and my my
um ex-boyfriend um who's still my friend
jason schwartzman he was friends with
some people in brian's band so by the
end you know we were all pals and then
we'd met brian and his family and
everything so i knew them from that and
then years later
um
he has a wonderful manager named jean
and she she asked they they were doing
something
an interview at the hollywood bowl and
they wanted somebody who's like a real
fan but also a musician
um
to interview him and so they asked me
because they knew what a fan i was and
so
i interviewed him
and then
what was it i don't think that like just
over the years and then um i we covered
god only knows and then they
he really liked our version and then we
ended up doing
you know um
like uh filming a version together and
then he was making an album of duets and
he asked us to play on it oh my god and
so it's really it's been like such a
nice thing over the years to to know him
and then you know he he he asked she and
him to open for him and we weren't able
to but matt
my bandmate did
open for him many times and when they
went through la like um
matt and i
went and sang
on stage with that is wild it's like
it was it's been really
that's so cool so i didn't know that she
and i yeah so i i've been lucky to to
get to do stuff like that
i wow but growing up i'm trying to think
like other people like i i had a lot of
like joni mitchell
i love tony mitchell huge shona mitchell
like i know there are like probably
three or four albums i just like i could
sing some from start to finish yeah
along with from start to finish um carol
king especially from a songwriting
standpoint um
huge fan um
and then like a lot of jazz singers
um like ella fitzgerald sarah vaughn
yeah
anita o'day um keeley smith
um well that's what your sound is a lot
definitely more old-fashioned i mean i
mean yeah well i would listen so judy
garland was like my idol growing up like
that was who i watched wizard of oz like
over and over again and i just was
obsessed with her and so it was like she
was like the first singer i was like
that is the most beautiful voice i've
ever heard
um
so she was kind of like my first
you know obsession and then
it was like you know kind of vocal
soloists like that you know um and then
um and then the harmony really i i love
the harmonies of like you know beatles
beach boys zombies oh yeah kinks yeah
so at what point did you so you were
already acting by the time you thought
how did the music thing come about how
did you find um uh matt i was it was
weird i was always doing both and in
high school i was in bands and also
doing you know and i i loved doing
you know acting and then when it was
there was wasn't really a lot of musical
theater opportunities other than my
first job and so
i was
you know i was sort of forced to um just
like focus like as an ad you know once i
got an agent they're like oh well you're
auditioning for movies and tv shows and
of course i'm happy and i'm not even
thinking like oh this is going to make
it so you i can't have a music career i
wasn't thinking that at all but what was
weird is i remember i was writing music
all the time
and kind of just keeping it to myself
and then
people kind of start saying like oh well
if you
have a career as an actor nobody would
ever take you seriously as a musician
i'm like but i was always a musician and
i was always reading songs
so
it was this thing that kept me from
doing it for actually like a long time
when you say people recorded my first
record until i was 26. that's what what
people do you mean like people in the
industry like like agents everybody
everyone said that and it was
it was no like the people that
the people that
had
tried
like people would kind of like chuckle
oh yeah make fun of them you know like
oh that person's like you know it was
like some vanity yeah yeah so we had so
when i
met matt i met matt uh ward uh working
on a movie
he was doing the soundtrack and i was a
fan of his and i met him and we recorded
a song together for the movie and um
he and i just worked so well together
and i kind of mustered up the courage to
send him all you know a bunch of my
songs that i'd written
and he
you know wrote me back and said oh i
love these i'd love to produce them
and so i went up to portland we recorded
you know an album
um and
i'm thinking
i don't know
how i'm gonna put this out because like
no one's going to take me seriously
because i'm an actor
isn't that funny
you're really worried about that yeah i
know and then
and then um
like towards like while we're well i was
like once we finished we kind of like
mixed it and everything and
matt was like you know i'm really proud
of this i and if you want like a band me
i'd love to be in a band oh he proposed
it first i was like yeah i was like i
was so honored like i wouldn't have ever
imagined
you know somebody like that he you know
i mean it was just so uh so flattering
and so such an honor and so i was like i
mean i would love that so what was great
was we came up with a name that was i
wanted to come up with a name that was
kind of like generic you know like yeah
like you don't know you you know you
know it's a boy and a girl yeah well you
were using that you also like made like
using your pronouns cool before
it
became such a thing
well i don't know but yeah um so um so
so i was like you know it's a boy and a
girl but we sent out these
um like
samplers like of our first record we
signed to a label and then i was like i
don't want anyone to know it's me in the
band and i was like i'm okay if nobody
knows it's me yeah
not that i was like that famous or
anything but i've done a couple things
you know also you've been hearing
famously yeah also i've been hearing no
yeah yeah you're
you know that you won't be able to do
this for the longest time so um so we
sent out everything out to um critics
before they knew it was matt or me and
they
and we got tons of great reviews and
yeah um
people responded so well to this record
our first record and
so it was it was really wonderful
because
then they were like pleasantly surprised
that they felt so good
yeah yeah cause i felt like oh the music
just stands up exactly it has nothing to
do with music you're like i can't have
two separate jobs like lots of people
yeah you know are good at more than one
but also that the that the opposite
didn't happen i mean i know that you had
a fear of not being taken seriously
because of you but like but also that
people didn't
didn't give you good reviews based on
the fact that it was you or didn't want
to sign you based on that it was you but
you know what's the funny thing is that
this still follows me around and i i i
don't know what to make of it but um
people still think so the majority of
like she and him's original songs i've
written by myself i don't i don't
collect matt produces them
matt is a an amazing songwriter like he
writes like all of his m ward stuff he's
incredible yeah i love him
i i write
um
i write
the songs
um the lyrics and the music and i
you know like i
like
write that yeah yeah yeah from scratch
yeah yeah in my home without co-writers
with charlie and
well charlie's an inspiration he's my
muse um
and
no matter what i do
nobody and it can be in our at the first
thing that in our bio and matt will say
we'll be in interviews and that will be
like zoe writes really good songs he'll
say it like pointing at me and they'll
still be like so matt since you write
the music and zoe writes the lyrics or
matt since you write all the songs
always such a good singer i'm like how
much do i have to do how many times do i
have to say that i write this like that
i write the music and and for people to
believe me do it like do i need to put
like a video like a nest cam like inside
my music the album has to be called
written written and arranged by zoe
dashner
by she and right well and matt does an
incredible job producing the song yeah
like and listen like that they're like
like all the credit like when he writes
his solo stuff obviously
i like to share yeah yeah yeah like he
is as much a part of no no of course
i am but like it's just hard when you
that's always taken away from you
like no matter what you do and it's
really funny because i was talking to my
friend becky stark who is a great
songwriter and singer from the band
lavender diamond um
wonderful i mean just such a talent
and i was like you know i thought it was
because i was an actor and she's like no
it's because you're a woman she's like
everyone does the same thing to me to
all she's like no matter what i do
nobody thinks that i write nobody thinks
i could possibly write it's like people
it's like unfathomable like unfathomable
that i could write my own songs even
females journalists even
is it is it a purely moment everyone
yeah and and when i tell people their
minds are blown
i'm like but you're all women
even like
and also the other thing is that like
you know i could be
like i didn't go to you know jazz school
yeah that's true
but i can still write a song that has
like changes key in the middle of the
song and it can be a conscious choice i
might not know like all the proper lingo
to tell you yeah like you know
um but that's just because i didn't
realize
new england conservatory music but i
still can write a song that's like
that's so complex and interesting right
so
god you know i i i i this is going to
sound so um ignorant of you know the
times that we live in but i just would
have assumed that that
that was a thing of the past
people lit well i don't know whether
it's conscious but people literally
ignore it every single time
i do and i at this point i
and it's funny i'll see like what we go
out and do um shows like around the
holidays because we put out the two
christmas records and it was so funny
because i'm like every single time i see
this thing i'm like
like it's like
um we're
we played a show and then someone's like
writing a review and and my dad sent it
to me he's like look at this great
review and the first thing is like
singer songwriter who's oh no it was
songwriter producer m ward and singer
actress zoey dc i'm like
or or they won't even say i'm a singer
they just say acting silly
yeah personality okay guys what am i
doing here and i'm like what am i doing
here i'm just acting the songs that that
i'm just a big puppy
and it's one of these fears like actors
have is that you're just like a puppet
nobody wants you to have ideas you know
well is it it must be strange but it
also must be
fulfilling at least you
you know i mean at least yeah well i
know and you know matt is like so
incredibly supportive and he's always
like i love producing your songs he's
like i love getting like he's like i get
so excited when i see like a song of
yours in my inbox yeah he's so
supportive and it's so nice and the
people who know you know it's just
always like funny i'm like
anna like i don't even not like i don't
know actually matt and i wrote our first
song together we were writing a little
song that we were commissioned to write
for like a soundtrack and um
and uh
it was really fun writing with him but
i'd never done it before it was like the
first time we ever did it this year
we've been working together first so he
does write the songs he's yours
well now he can take credit for all of
them because he yeah because he we
collaborated
it also it must be
frustrating because they they're just so
good too i mean they're they're yeah um
you know i'm
i'm such a fan of the but but um
it must that must be part of the an
element of the the
frustration how could a little girl like
you write a good song it's weird
yeah totally
um
i i remember you sent you sent me you
had recorded love hurt
as good as your writing is but remember
when you quoted love herds yeah
yeah great i'm always doing that stuff
yeah yeah well he he he recorded a great
version of it with emmy lou harris
that's right god i love him i got to
play with it i i got to play shows with
emmy lou harris a number no [ __ ]
oh yeah love emmy lou hair um wow that
is really cool uh well do you get
is it harder to do that do you get
nervous around people that you
you admire like that
you know
no cause like
i think
like
uh you know we can all fill in like i
got
i've gotten i don't know why i think
it's just because like i love music and
they love music and that's a you know
just an immediate point of connection
and i also like don't have a need to
like i don't feel like to please
like yeah like i'm like if you need me
like i can sing harmony i can like you
know i can but i don't have to i'm just
you know i'm i don't want anything from
them i just like you know if if somebody
i meeting somebody admire like you know
it's
it's great but i'm i think like
ultimately the
passion for music like kind of um like
supersedes any celebrity supersedes any
celebrity thank you i was gonna say
super seeds and i was like is that the
right yeah i was gonna say like
overwhelmed i don't know yeah isn't it
on a podcast when you use when you land
on the wrong word
and it just keeps going and like you
can't go back and say you know what the
thing i said a couple minutes ago um but
you're it's it makes sense when zoey
when you talk about your musical
inspirations because like you really got
a hold on me i i your song she belongs i
the ones that i really like cherish that
i listen to on regular rotation
have such an old-fashioned
feel you must hear that a lot that they
have such um they're throwback yeah i
mean we do cover a lot of old songs so
we love covering songs we did a whole i
mean we did our christmas records that
are all covered but we did a a record
that was all covers called classics and
then we did
then we always do a couple on every
record and it's really fun to to
reinvent old songs like you know make
them our own and
we got to you know covering you really
got a hold on me um
like big fan of smokey robinson such a
great song yeah and
um i kept seeing him in um
oh what is it um the tsa checks before
you get on the airplane oh really
and i wanted to tell him because for a
while oh actual him actually him
actually smokey robin
like in random places i kept seeing him
weird like i and i wanted to tell him
because we recorded his song and for a
while that was like one of our always on
spotify when i look up like our chops on
yeah like that was one of them like and
i was like wow that was on our first
record we recorded it all live just like
one take
um
and it was really like a just a sweet
you know it was like
one take live two mike it was super you
know
um kind of bare bones but it was it was
a really special recording and i kind of
wanted and whenever we play it live
people like freak out that's so good
why not go up to him why why would you
hesitate i'm i don't you know oh sorry
i've just i think i have a tambourine on
the floor it sounded like a camera
um you know what i um
i'll go up to somebody thinking they're
gonna appreciate it sometimes they're
really nice
but sometimes you catch them off guard
they're not they don't appreciate it
they don't want to be you know made
uncomfortable yeah and i just don't ever
want that feeling yeah you air on the
side of
caution air on the side of caution you
know because i just don't want to make
anybody feel uncomfortable like i i know
everyone's different some people are
really private life could be a dream
sweetheart
[Music]
hello hello again you're booming we'll
meet again
[Music]
i gotta ask you about 500 days of summer
i know we're running out of time um
i love that movie so much what what was
um
uh was it difficult i always wondered
was it difficult to keep track of where
your character was when you guys are
shooting just because it it's jumping
around all the time how did you
track that that's an interesting that's
a really interesting question so
my
my goal in that movie
was to not
like i
to reveal enough of
who she was to
for
her to create like
enough to like for him to create a
fantasy of her i guess
but not so much that because part she
doesn't give herself over entirely she
doesn't give herself over entirely
because she's not actually that
interested in him
and like even though it's an extremely
romantic movie
and they do have a romantic um
you know
they have a romantic time together um
like she doesn't see herself with him
yeah
and it's very disappointing like to me
too i think like those characters should
be together but you know
kind of what's interesting about that
movie
is that it's
from his point of view yeah um and
and then and because of that like
you can't fully know her
that's interesting even
he even drowns her out with his narrator
when she finally said when she finally
says like i've never told this to
anybody i can't remember what that was
yeah but they're like she's like they're
in like pajamas they're in bed like yeah
she's like i've never told this to
anybody and then the narrator interrupts
her this like
older yeah
guy
and he felt so special that she was and
she went on and said some blah blah blah
blah blah blah
i'm like
and so it's so funny to me when people
come up to me and are like a few summer
i'm like
okay
he wouldn't even listen to her like he
had this one like he had a great fantasy
life about her but he wasn't interested
in her yeah you're right and that was
that much she really was that must have
been in this you
like expectations versus reality was
like that little kind of yes
thing that happens like at the party at
the end but that's really the whole
movie up to that point is actually
you're right you're right and
everything's through this lens of like
like manic pixels i mean that you that's
another romanticism and manic pixie
dreams dream girls aren't real so
um yeah i mean they never saw her for
herself like she wasn't allowed to be
anything other than you know a perfect
you know and and no one really when it
comes down to it wants to be perfect
they want to be able to have flaws
accepted for them yeah
was that an appeal zoe of the the new
girl script when you read liz's script
was that that she was so flawed i mean
that that it was an exploration of this
yeah yes i liked that i liked that she
was really liz mayweather so amazingly
talented such a great writer and
and i just loved that um
that the character
was
kind of the character that would have
been
a lot of times a friend and yeah
not the leader yeah um
look at judy grier characters that i
found most interesting yeah and that's
kind of what she was set out to do was
like write this character that was like
very emotional you know like super you
know like guileless and sweet and
well-meaning but makes mistakes and does
things wrong you know like
um
and is is you know very sensitive and
you know likes all this kind of girly
stuff and you know it was like it it was
it was great it was like a something i
could bring a lot of my
self to but also like invent new things
for the character did she it was
exciting to be bad did she write it for
you zoe
not that i know of she was like writing
it kind of based on her own ex
in in some ways but then changed a lot
you know like not not the not the plot
but i think she would like go
on the subway or something and sing a
theme song for her
like her yeah
her sitcoms
that she was living
um but her life like wasn't glamorous
and like she thought i think that was
like what it was like the unglamorous
life that you're making a sick comment
you know
and um what what similarities do you
have you must be sick of answering this
what what are the similarities between
you and jess
um
i mean
i think like a lot of her
interests are probably like similar to
mine um
like she's very
you know i'm kind of girly i i
i always like girly stuff like ever
since i was a kid you know um
um she's kind of nerdy about
various things crafting
speaking like all that yeah
yeah
yeah and um
did you do a lot during the pandemic did
you do even more oh yeah so much cooking
yeah i was cooking like crazy
and it was it was great we were all i
felt like we were so healthy it wasn't
like i was and i would be cooking stuff
that wasn't like i didn't think was that
healthy but it makes you realize like
that restaurants aren't cooking because
we were like i would felt like very fit
during pandemic
once you start to eat more restaurants
you're like why are they putting in the
food and when you're cooking and you're
like god it's this much olive oil and
this might like this can't be that and
uh yeah it's true once you realize how
much because i you know i would think i
i'm not like it's not like i was cooking
like healthy like all the time but but
in comparison to restaurants i guess it
was what is your specialty if you if you
were if somebody really impressive you
wanted to impress somebody coming like
the obamas were coming over what would
you oh my god
well i grew up so my parents lived in
italy oh wow before i was born and so i
grew up like um
i grew up uh eating a lot of pasta and
risotto um
and uh i probably make risotto because i
can make a really good one and um like a
really proper
one and a lot of times you go to a
restaurant and they mess it up and i'm
like i can actually do it without
messing up it's just a matter of slow do
that is it you have to just patience
yeah it takes you have to
stand over the pot for 20 minutes
straight stirring you can't like leave
it
you know and you have to add your hot
water and not hot water your hot bra
yeah like as it's and then wait for it
to absorb and then add more and then
wait for it to absorb so it takes
yeah and then you add like depending
upon what ingredients you're cooking you
add them at different times but i know
it because my parents were making it
always when i was growing up i would
help them
everything so that that to me is very
very
like i know it and i know how to make it
well and as long as everyone's sitting
at the table when it's ready yeah if
it's
if you wait
it's not good anymore ah okay all right
well hopefully and that'd be hard to
tell the make like a a cake or you know
arancini which is like a bomb
yeah those are so kind yeah um well and
really quick so now we have a lightning
round at the end of every episode so
okay fantastic uh
the the show you're doing welcome to our
show is was part of the impetus for
doing that just to
hang out with those guys again did you
yes yeah i bet i bet yes i text them all
the time yeah i text all of them all the
time yeah i love them so much i miss
them
i missed like the camaraderie i did a
couple episodes i miss them
i know i love everyone so much and so
um i was texting you know
lamorn and hannah
all the time and i also still text max
and jake all the time too
um i'm not on like the guy's text
there's this like guy's texture yes i
don't know what's on there well i know i
i know probably a good thing i'm not i
know i talked to jake about it and jake
was like if max were to call me or vice
i think they both said this i'd be
horrified because once in a while i get
a facetime
from somebody yeah and you know when you
get a facetime now it's like what are
they thinking like you gotta really like
commit to that um i know it's a lot it's
a lot so um yeah so i was like you know
yeah and i really miss them and it's
like you know in l.a everyone lives in
different neighborhoods so it's like i
wouldn't get to see them totally
and they were my family for seven years
so
now we do it re remotely but we're all
uh you're going to see it i can't wait
i'm going to do it soon 12 minutes but
um
um but yeah it was basically to see my
work family again and get to
um talk to some of our you know like
other people that we worked with like
yours yes well i can't wait um uh okay
we're doing it soon lightning round what
is your favorite emoji zoe
zuzu
the little smiley face with the hearts
around it oh yeah yeah um i use it all
at all yeah that class classic um who
was your first celebrity crush
i think like macaulay culkin okay yep
yeah
yes
from party monster
um
[Laughter]
from you know when i was like a little
kid he was like a little kid an actor it
was like the only little kid actor i
knew of and i was like yeah i was like i
guess that's who i'm supposed to like
yeah mine was um the princess in
neverending story
uh oh well she's just yes done and i
just read a thing recently where she had
i think i think she just stopped acting
after that she was the opposite of you
she did one
yeah um
um what is your favorite ice cream
flavor
um
that's hard i know like raelians and
cream oh yeah probably which is is there
i like one like one like that but with
like a chocolate ribbon oh yeah involved
like a caramel chocolate with a praline
involved uh favorite holiday
zoe's favorite house christmas christmas
yes um do you say you have two christmas
albums
yes oh nice okay i only have very she
and him christmas and christmas party
okay
a christmas party is one i have to get
check it out i'm going to
what is what is an acclaimed movie that
you are embarrassed to admit you haven't
seen people are like shame you for the
matrix oh yeah yeah you might hang up
immediately when i tell you i have not
seen the entirety of dirty dancing i
actually haven't even
okay
all right well that's yeah i guess we
are quirky so here's what's interesting
about dirty dancing it came out when i
was i was living i was a kid and we
lived in london for a year
and it came out in the u.s then and it
wasn't really a movie i would have been
able to see anyway it came out when i
was you know
seven or something and then when i came
back it it it so it
normally they were getting movies like a
year later oh yeah
in england so i just totally missed that
movie i just never saw it and then i saw
like i've seen parts of it i haven't
seen the whole movie oh wow okay i
probably should have watched it like
well i saw the making of it you know
that thing on netflix where it's like
the movies that we alpha's one i saw
that one the movies that we love oh yeah
you should see it no
am i in it you're all over it
um it's mostly about you was that hard
that's so funny
was there a lot of like uh outtakes like
cracking up with will ferrell
did you break i i'm sure i did i'm sure
yeah i mean i remember like the stuff
with him like jumping on santa claus to
pick santa claus that stuff i remember i
actually do remember like hiding behind
something because i was laughing i
didn't want to ruin it
that is the best
that happened a lot to me on new girl um
what is a game show pat oh by the way
the game show you do is so good oh
thank you i don't know if it's coming
that i don't think it's coming back i
love doing it it's so much so good
it was so fun it was such an
old-fashioned kind of like
tongue-in-cheek delivery it was really
fun um thank you uh what what is a game
show pastor president uh that you'd
you'd like to be on that i like yeah
you'd like that you'd want to be a
contestant
i don't know they make me nervous okay
okay that's it
that's a just
answer is there a scrabble game show
because i'm good at scrabble there
should be we should um we should do one
uh do you drink coffee or tea and how do
you take it
oh coffee although you love um so in the
morning i drink it with heavy cream oh
wow nice
isn't that crazy no i just love it it's
delicious
yeah people think i'm a maniac no no
i'll put heavy cream on uh on cheerios
on cereal so milk not entirely but like
i'll just top it off on a naughty
morning
it
when when you've had heavy cream on
something it's your hard to go back
nothing is better
i mean like granola oh the best you're
like
i'll say granola and cheerios that was
my favorite combination bottom layer
granola top it off with cheerios milk
and heavy duty um so in the afternoon or
like in the later morning i'll have like
an almond milk latte or something
um but yeah
when i wake up it's heavy yeah wow okay
that's a scoop um if if you could learn
another language what would it be
um
romantically it would be
portuguese because i i would just love
to sing in portuguese
um i just think it's such a beautiful
language um
practically spanish because it's very
useful
um
but
yeah um yeah
um what is your favorite cereal
granola oh yeah you have a special you
have a brand you love yes it's called
um
purely elizabeth oh yes yes purely
elizabeth yes it's it's good
okay it's so funny because it takes me
forever to settle on a and i was mulling
that over the other day i went between
the kind
purely elizabeth i will try it next time
i love it
there's like a chocolate uh
eating that brand for like 10 years okay
wow and you i owe it i still buy other
granolas too but
i always go back okay it's so good and
and they have so
they have a good grain free one but i
like the one with the grains in it it
has a quinoa and amaranth it's not just
like oats okay very but it's the sweet
salt balance on that and the crunch
factor yeah so oh good that's what's
hard to get chocolate sea salt one
that's amazing
okay so yeah i'm doing it i'm going back
everyone loves okay whoa you better get
a ton of jury's in
okay
uh you heard it here well if you had to
um if you had to choose a different
first name
of course zoe and zuzia were both great
names what would it be
i said i've thought about this a lot
because as a kid i didn't like my name
but now i mean i like it and it's me
yeah um
if i had a different person when you
were a kid what did you want
isabelle oh wow i don't know yeah it's
not it's supposed to be um like i wanted
like names or um natasha uh-huh oh like
a russian um
or my middle name is claire and i like
that name and i for a while tried to get
people to call me claire but nobody yeah
they're like
uh if you had a sandwich named after you
what would be on it the zoe deschanel
sandwich would consist of one okay
well my i'm a vegetarian so there would
not be any meat okay um
it would be
um
sourdough oh no no no rye okay
right toasted roasted rye i'm writing
down um okay
cheddar cheese cheddar
um
dill pickle relish yes still has to be
do
yeah mm-hmm um
[Music]
like uh
uh spicy brown mustard okay
shredded lettuce yes
okay shredded i like that um
much better than just like yes
which can get soggy and weird yes
um
uh
let's see what would be good no and it's
pretty good i mean yeah that sounds kind
of a basic scenario but
but it's it's a good do you have a
protein on that
well cheese is protein how about um a uh
and uh over easy oh great okay
that sounds delicious
um i mean it seems good right i'd eat
that how about hot sauce on it too hot
sauce wow okay
why not the zoe destinal sounds
delicious um
what is your favorite tom hanks movie
i love tom hanks all of them
good answer
okay but i'm gonna say
are we going drama are we going to come
it is totally up to you i would like to
now hear your favorite drama and comedy
okay
um
drama saving private ryan
um comedy
um i thought that was the comedy oh no
wait
[Laughter]
comedy and i would say shout out to
philadelphia which is so great but it's
also sad so sometimes i'm like
like like
i'm it's so sad yeah i know dramas can
be sad but
yeah it's hard to watch so especially
during the
pandemic yeah pandemic um all right
really quick would you rather take a
time machine to the past or the future
yes
obviously
are you more of a talker or a texter
talker
uh i mean but well i will so it depends
on if i know if i know you a talker like
i love to talk on the phone like
especially if you're like really close
with me
but
with like people i'm not as familiar
with i'm a texter because um i'm a
little bit
shy well not shy but i get like um i get
overwhelmed by phone calls if there are
too many people i have to go it's also
hard to get off phone calls sometimes
sometimes i have i i have a fear of how
am i going to get
as as now i'm now thinking about this
this um zoom because i know we have to
get on the other zoom
um beach or mountains
mountains uh
now do you have an opinion about toilet
roll over or under do you have strong
feelings well i don't have an opinion
but my boyfriend does so i have to do it
the way he
lies because he's specific over yes
likewise he's like mad if you think
under he's like he's like you're
you're wrong yeah i agree with him um
finish the sentence please life is short
so
life is short so have fun this was so
fun
this was so bad
thanks for having me i missed you this
is gonna be i can't wait
thank you
it's out
it's it's out um every monday we have an
episode and you're gonna be on it i'm so
excited
right now
[Music]
it's very hard to but it's um there's
some i'll tell you what it's definitely
not bad no i know i know it's uh that
was a i was always fine she has such a
great voice and she has such like um
a buttery
smooth clear voice i know it is buttery
and what you just did i know what it was
funny sounding
it sounded nothing like her nor did my
impression i know i i bailed after the
first crack i i used to do an impression
of blake lively and i was like oh and
she would say oh that's not what i sound
like oh and and it was people would be
like it's not really what she sounds
like but it's kind of there's an essence
yeah it's like dana carvey doing george
bush
really yeah i know i guess so yeah
anyway but her voice but her voice is
it's like any great
singer i love when greatness are hearing
them talk because you know amy ma'am
yeah look at me man you can hear the
great singer in their speaking voice
yeah
yeah she is uh man i love i i would love
to see them play again i i um
it's been a while i saw them playing i
think irving plaza who shared him yeah i
saw both she and him you did you saw
them live yes i'd like to see that oh
great i took damien really yeah i think
he enjoyed it uh anyway
she does have
you said this to her like a
kind of an old-fashioned and i and i
don't know is there something insulting
about email crooner saying that to
someone though like um
i don't kind of a throwback oh
a throwback style i i don't think so
right
i don't but i think you're right it like
it makes sense to me that she
idolized judy garland oh yeah like that
i mean if you were to say like you have
an old-fashioned acting style that might
be insulting only because
there was a stop there was a time like
marlon brando kind of changed acting
into a more isn't that amazing that one
person i mean there were others from
that school from from
[Music]
uh the act the actor's studio but like
that he changed it from into a more
natural
form
yeah but see i would i would
wonder if people who loved those old
pre-marlon brando era movies
would disagree with that they would say
oh no i prefer the action yeah maybe
maybe for sure this is what you're used
to maybe yeah i think so allow me to
pivot yeah uh when she was talking about
her
children
who
i can i put money on the fact that
they're adorable even though i've never
seen them adorkable knowing how adorable
zoe deschanel is yes did i say that
about a grown woman yes well i just did
well well she is described as such on
the show in fact that's they there's
something a little condescending about
adorable maybe
someone
my age calling i'm not like 80. yeah it
depends on how you say it i mean you
didn't say it in a i don't think your
tone i don't know who knows who knows um
but speaking of adorable personality
don't get mad yes her kids um you know
what this i think this is a good idea
and you alluded to it when you were
talking to her her kids come up with
these stories that story blueberry that
had nothing to do with blueberries yeah
funny don't you think it'd be a good
idea to have adults and like a proper
like professional film crew
make these things that kids come up with
and just yes like in an experimental way
and like have professional crews and
actors and and just let a kid yeah
you know go with their imagination yeah
and just see what comes out it'd be
funny in a funny experimental way that
would be great but like taken seriously
have really good actors do yeah yeah be
funny
and like think obviously things wouldn't
connect and make sense all the time and
yeah and there would be no reason for it
to be called blueberry but wouldn't that
be part of the charm i think so like a
huge part of the chart i think so that'd
be funny i think so that story about
she and him is is interesting to me in
that they tried to think the most
generic
vague name for the band because in part
she didn't want yes to to be associated
well to like get a record deal or based
on she thought of based on her act her
name as an actress yeah and she was
right to do that because the fact that
people don't generally don't think of
her as the person who writes
the
music
i think it's i would guess i mean
it's sexist
but it's also the fact that she's a
famous actress and people
know her so well as a famous actress
that they assume that anything she does
musically yeah is like a pet project
sometimes some like side things she's
doing and that it's that she's not like
a fully legitimate right musician who's
capable of writing these great songs
right that somebody is kind of
piggybacking off of her fame like right
somebody else is like pulling the
strings the fact that they introduced
them even as like m ward uh producers
i know and zoe
that must be really frustrating but i
think her instinct was right to try to
try to kind of hide her name yeah when
she thought of the
band's name well and and it was a
different time too i mean people younger
people listen might think like why why
should that matter and like why would
that be a concern but i think because
now i think things are so blended i
think that things are more blended i
mean i i think
zoe deschanel's is such a unique
talent as both an actor and a musician
that it's
it's like impossible to say
that you know she's this but she also
does this and vice versa you know to me
it's like
there could be two completely separate
people who have extremely impressive
careers doing both of these things
that's true and she just happens to be a
very rare case that is who's someone who
is like amazing at both yeah that's true
but you guys a new girl i mean that
relationship is like
iconic now people the fact that people
are still talking about this few
episodes
it feels really it's pretty wild wild i
i still i'm telling you like you know
people will come up to me and they'll
say especially younger people and
they'll say oh my god you're you're the
actor an actor
and those just say that from new girl
you know i bet if there was a spin-off
show about your character from that show
it would be huge i you know i've been uh
thinking about it a genslinger
again spin-off show i've been thinking
about it because this character was so
fun to do i remember like when they call
me back to do i did because i did later
episodes when she talks about josh gad
like later
uh in that season and then a couple
seasons later i'd always get so excited
because i think
well i i really loved being around those
guys obviously like we talked about that
a lot on the show but um man zoey but i
i just love that character there's
something like
did we talk about this on this i'm
getting confused because i did zoe's
podcast right after we did this one so i
don't know if we talked about the the
the bill murray comparison uh no i don't
think so no well there was something and
she used the word guileless which i
think was really app apt um but the
character was so guileless there was
something he was such like an innocent
and positive that uh
it was it he wasn't dumb but i got to
play a version of dumb of like not
knowing
uh socially and it's it was so fun to do
and i was thinking about bill murray and
what about bob bill bill murray is a
little bit like that there's also i
think a sweetness
and uh like a naivete to that character
that
i you know look at how popular ted lasso
is that show that like a character who's
so
positive yeah
uh i i think that show would really work
it'd be fun especially if you had a
counterpoint who was like which is why
doing stuff with jake johnson was fun
because he was such a grouch he was such
a like cynical kind of um he represented
probably the way
i probably most people are
uh when they're when they're with
somebody like
my character genslinger and
so yeah it'd be great to do
and it'd also be great to like
i don't know i wonder if those guys
would be into it i should reach out to
them about it i'm sure they would be
into the popping by you know popping by
saying hi yeah
doing course characters again of course
uh 500 days of summer is so good god
what a good movie that is i know i know
it's interesting i never thought of it
that way before she explained
and it makes once she said i was like of
course that that's what it is it's the
whole thing is from his perspective
uh yes i know i never thought about
hopefully a future guest
and that and i forgot about that scene
when she's finally
uh
talking about something
like the way she feels about something
something very important yes and it's
drowning it's cut off by this narrator
that represents him well maybe this is
my male arrogance because watching it i
it never occurred to me me too you don't
both have to male arrogance when
watching a great romantic comedy from a
male's perspective i know i didn't
realize that but yeah i know
total especially now having written
movies and stuff like can you imagine
doing that in like but but it's it's
so well not and it's truly not meant to
be balanced that i didn't realize which
which makes the ending and that kind of
the fantasy split screen
make a lot more sense like there was
reality and the way he saw it and and
that's such a great way of looking at a
relationship it's such an interesting
lens to to see it through in a movie
yeah
so well directed too that movie is so
welcoming no we had we had the dep
a year later do um
going the distance and i remember
yeah i just wish um going distance is a
good movie too it's a good movie it's
underrated you said you put heavy cream
on your cheerios sometimes oh yeah i
have it in a while on naughty mornings i
said that yes
[Laughter]
oh that would be a tough one to see in
print
that'd be a tough quote to see
yeah it's true i haven't done it in a
long time but um how good is that do you
remember that do you remember doing like
a layer of granola then cheerios on top
yeah when i was a child yeah well heavy
cream on cheerios
when was last time you did that have you
done it in in this century
have you done that in the 21st century i
bet i have you know when i have you know
when i remember doing it when i had
heavy cream that was going to expire
that i knew i wasn't going to use for
like to make anything but what oh really
yeah so it's circumstantial it's not
because no i don't go out of my way
naughty mornings don't come from being
hungover or something no no no hungover
mornings i i i'll stick with the greeny
shout out by the way to kimberly snyder
she's got a new book out yeah um and uh
she's she's the one that got us into the
greenies into the greeny mornings but
they
i can't say enough about them uh and and
she's a great nutritionist hey let's
read a letter okay
that's my guilt from not having like
posted about her
okay here we go from
zach mingy minji
spell it m-i-n-g-i-e
mingi mingi zak mingi subject people
call me josh
it's weird
hello justin and christian my name is
zach my girlfriend and i are big fans of
the pod ah thanks zack or maybe josh
we recently bought a house and we've
really enjoyed listening to you guys
while we do our renovation projects
christian as well i just bought a house
and my middle name is zach yes wow
we especially love the lightning round
questions and hearing how people's
answers compare to our own that's cool
that's good to hear yes i sometimes
wonder if like
are people into this part
um i'm into it that's good i know i'm
it's good to know we have three things
in common house name i'm into the
lightning round okay well we should be
friends uh well let's see if he gets
there okay let's not jump the gun okay
am i too eager you are being that's
unlike you
uh on the zachary levi episode we
freaked out when he said that people
have always called him josh because the
exact same thing happens to me
weird strangers strangers assume my name
is josh and people that have known me my
entire life would just accidentally call
me josh at random times this got us
wondering if this is an endemic problem
among zach's weird i don't see how it
could be that's funny an endemic problem
amongst acts it might it must just be
a coincidence i think exactly i think
it's more to do zac levi looks like a
josh you know what's funny doesn't he
yes more than a zack um anyway sorry
back to zach oh weird pivot
that's something you would say you've
said that he wrote pivot yes pivotal
cohen is he my um wow your friend soul
mate
maybe
uh pivot would you rather have a great
movie made about your life that
something tells me this is going to be a
great would you rather
pivot would you rather have a great
movie made about your life that
portrayed you in a bad light or a
interesting or a bad movie made about
your life that portrayed you in a great
light hmm whoa that is that's a good
question uh i have an answer keep up the
good work guys thanks zach that is such
a good question um
i have an answer i do too it's a bad
movie what's your answer bad movie about
it why it's been a great time why though
well because i i i care i think i care
more about
um
a perception i care more about being
like good to people and being like a
good person than i do about
having like some
great art made about me and so
if the art is not very good i i you know
i'd rather be i i'd like to think of
myself i i would hope that it's a at
least a reflection of
who i am
my nature my character
and so i i care more about my own
character i think than like well it's
true now i'm thinking about it from your
perspective and it's it's such a
different question for you because your
life is
is like
maybe not kind of maybe not ripe for
for a movie to be made about it but but
it's but it's
potentially such a boring movie no but
it wouldn't because you've had you had
uh uh relatively speaking relative to
the two people who are sitting uh in
this room right now a very interesting
life
and compared i would say relative to a
lot of people it's i know but you've had
a lot of interesting experiences but but
it's not stuff that hasn't been dealt
with in movies or hasn't been like
taught we talked about on the podcast i
mean it's like that's true what what's
interesting to me i don't know i i kind
of disagree i'm not being self-effacing
i like
but but for me
a movie about my life i've had funny
experiences but a movie about my life
like where i was the main character in
the story would be so dreadfully boring
so that even if i disagree even even a
good movie where i was portrayed in a
negative light would be so boring and
like not worthy of being made i think
you're selling some of your experiences
you're funny i mean you have some so
many funny stories i think you're
selling those short if they but
especially if it was like a licorice
pizza type movie well i haven't seen it
but
um but as a character i mean it's hard
to imagine this because if i'm
if i'm portrayed in a negative light
that would mean that i'm an interesting
enough character that i could be
portrayed in in a negative light you
know what i'm saying yes i do and i
don't and that's this is this might
sound arrogant but like i don't think
i
could be in a realistic way because
i'm not interesting enough
but i wouldn't be either i mean how i
don't know i mean i i know what you're
saying i think
it would also i mean the main great
movie people would remember that i mean
people that's true remember like then
you become
then that colors i mean it would color
the way everyone in the world thought of
you it would also be so much funnier to
have a bad movie out there where
regardless of how i'm portrayed i think
it'd be funnier to have a really bad
movie about me out there
but
the the downside in having that is
it runs
it runs the risk of being like a little
like propaganda or something you know i
feel like
uh kim jong-un would have a movie made
about him i bet he like making him look
really good like a hero but it would
probably be stupid but it'd be funny
wouldn't it would it be
it'd be funny but i wouldn't want people
my point is i wouldn't want people to
think that i was behind
uh this propaganda piece yeah you know
you're saying like i financed it somehow
and i'm like
you know you would have a great movie
made about you that portrayed you in a
bad life no i would still i would still
uh i would still have a bad movie made
but but i'm saying the one reason that i
would that would give me pause
is that i wouldn't want people to think
that it's propaganda that i paid for
well you'd have to
you'd have to just i don't know it's a
good question that's a really good
question now i'm thinking about if kim
jong-un did have a movie made about
which i'm sure he had well whatever
if he did do you think he would cast an
actor that was like
slightly overweight like at all
overweight he would cast like that um
or like henry golding
yeah
like a really handsome person
yes yes a handsome but not like a little
dough ball
oh man
i hope you found this canceled by him
because if you get canceled not canceled
killed but that's canceled to him if he
cancels you you're dead
whatever he's not listening to this he
might you know i've thought about that
before i he's definitely seen some of
your movies that's what i wonder he's
100 so you think he knows who i am yes
so what if he likes me
do you what if he likes you so much
and he's hearing this and he's gonna
like cancel you
aren't you scared now i'm a little
scared
thank you to um to zach my future best
friend what a great letter man and to
our iconic guest yeah zoey uh so good to
catch up with you when i say iconic i
don't mean the way that younger people
use their words they do a lot it's very
they say casually everyone's iconic yeah
she's actually iconic yes zoey deschanel
yeah and you know what else they say a
lot i've noticed on instagram they say
king this is
that's arrogant to say that they say it
a lot but like i've heard
it instead of saying like i really like
you as an actor they say king oh really
yeah you know they also say about
middle-aged men i think it's older
people they say dad or
dad daddy daddy yeah daddy yeah
well anyway yeah well sorry i
interrupted your thanking zoe oh yes um
mommy zoey the daddy likes to would like
to thank that's gross then that's like a
weird sexual ring to him you're a
fictional girlfriend yeah yeah god dude
we have fun and oh and check out um
her show her no welcome to our show to
our show uh which i'm sure you will it's
i think it's doing already doing i think
it was like the number one show before
it even came out but um the episode i
did for that was really fun we talked
about we kind of go more in depth into
the uh
the process of shooting it and some of
the fun some fun anecdotes but we
laughed so much doing that sex scene
what sex scene i said that weird i
thought he said sexy sex scene sex scene
uh also if anyone would like to write
into the show we really enjoy getting
your letters uh they don't have to all
be as impressive as that one no but
there's we've been getting some great
ones and so uh keep them keep them
coming at uh life is short
at wondering.com yes life is short at
wunderly.com and um
again big thanks to zoe and zach and all
the z names listening and kim yes and um
and everyone uh so thank you guys we we
so appreciate it
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's co-hosted by a and co-produced
by christian
other co-producers katie b allen and
megan the monaco senior producer is
michelle miesh
audio engineer sergio enriquez and the
executive producer president of the new
girl fan club yes the one and only
marshall louie and also the company that
we do it for is called wondering
[Music]
[Music]
love
hurts
love scars
[Music]
and
mars
any heart
[Music]
take a lot of pain
take a lot of pain
love is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
tell me
[Music]
tell me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you